if your organization has determined that
data governance will play an important
role
you'll need to know who will be impacted
and what these people will need to do
data governance doesn't necessarily have
to incur a lot of overhead cost
generally a big investment isn't
required in a whole bunch of new
software tools
where most overhead is felt is with the
introduction of new responsibilities for
individuals
in large organizations this may include
hiring more and more dedicated staff
this is not unusual as governance risk
and compliance requirements of many
industries require specialized skills
and onerous reporting of deliverables
let's talk about one of the most common
mistakes organizations make with data
it seems quite normal that we assign
people to own processes
such as the human resources director
who's accountable for recruitment or a
facilities manager who is responsible
for real estate needs
but when it comes to data we often don't
assign owners to that data
organizations omit to give
responsibility for the maintenance of
management of the data
it seems intuitive that the chief
financial officer should have
responsibility for protecting credit
card information
or the sales director should ultimately
own accurate monthly sales reports
let's be clear owning the data doesn't
mean it belongs to somebody
ownership means being held accountable
for such things as data integrity
security and compliance requirements
we want owners to really care about the
data with which they have been entrusted
since data governance is an enterprise
concern these data owners are ultimately
accountable to an authority that has an
enterprise perspective
with data flowing between systems
internally and externally
a single data owner has insufficient
visibility for an enterprise role
for this we need data stewards a data
steward can be a single individual
or a team of people the data steward is
the enterprise authority
it's the individual or team ultimately
responsible for data governance
they create the rules and processes for
governing data and anticipate that data
owners will follow those rules and
processes
who are these data stewards typically
they are existing members of your
organization
they might be people who by the nature
of their skills are well suited to
participating in a data oversight
capacity
data stewards usually conduct this role
for just a few hours a month
and spend the rest of their time in
their normal day jobs
the data steward function is often
called the data governance board
the data stewardship council or the data
governance office
in medium to large enterprises these
groups are made up of several data
stewards that represent the entirety of
the organization
to maintain independence data stewards
are typically different people than data
owners
the group's activities include agreeing
on data policy and procedures
resolving data challenges reviewing
concerns
and making strategic decisions regarding
the good management of data in the
enterprise
data stewards use information provided
by data owners and managers
and a wide range of stakeholders in
order to diligently conduct their work
the scope of data owners and data
stewards is an important organizational
decision
and should be determined in each
organization based on such dependencies
as maturity
scale and industry requirements